the bosses of Google Amazon Facebook and
Apple wield immense power the four tech
giants are sometimes known by the
acronym gaffer their products and online
services her almost global reach one of
their key assets is big data about
zillions of people and their preferences
it said the company's know more about us
than do our partners or doctors do you
find that scary
yes little and even why that yeah
because we could be sliding into a
situation in which we're no longer sure
if our wishes are really our own or if
they only seem to be our own because
these companies might one day be able to
present us with products opinions or
information that correspond to our taste
to what we're looking for at that very
moment these firms can play hardball one
example Google has an online price
comparison service when one does a
Google search for products and prices
ads appear at the top of the results
page these tend to be the ones it's
owned subsidiary has placed
[Music]
but yeah since the rollout of Google's
price comparison service and the way
we're placed lower down in search
results the generic ones that aren't
paid for we get less traffic or less
than you'd expect in a growing market
people always click on results at the
top of the page in the EU Google's price
comparison service has to compete fairly
with other portals for ad space at the
top of results pages Viki use
Competition Commissioner migrator vest
there find Google 2.4 billion euros for
abusing its market dominance in this
area plus the commercial Nick of the
commission didn't say this is what you
have to do all it said was you can't do
that you have to change it and so Google
responded in a creative manner to its
advantage if these Giants identify a
company as a significant threat they
often undermine it or acquire it for
example Facebook bought Instagram and
whatsapp there are calls to break the
dominance of big data powerhouses this
could be an for Clark one disposal is to
anonymize the data and make them
available to other companies to enable
competition is it realistic to think one
can curtail the power of these companies
yeah yes if there's the will and an
understanding of what needs to be done
thank you - on the farms have so far
been subjected to little regulation or
pushback from governments the EU being
perhaps a notable exception one problem
is the speed at which they change and
adapt another is their popularity they
provide free services to billions of
people under these circumstances it's
easy to overlook the risks